I'll be waiting for you, and I'll talk about the new machine learning functions
Playtech and Crash Phi.
These elements are supervised learning,
that is, a function to learn how to do a task from an example of that task.
There is also an image recognition task, and there is also a text classification task,
for example, you can classify a document according to a topic such as biophysics. In
general, Yuto is a function of all variables,
that is, predicting variables as a function of features.
Normally, when doing such a task, you have to be quite advanced in terms of algorithms,
especially about machine learning algorithms and
the types of my processing that you
need to do with your data.
These algorithms are all parameters and they are also.  You
also need to choose a method to find the optimal parameters.
We have automated all of these processes.
Automatic selection of pretreatment methods for children.
Experts have made automatic selection of parameters.
I made it possible to do machine learning using the Living Fight project without it.
This is a basic example of Living Phi. Living
Phi is for classifying the features of this example into classes, that is,
categorical variables, so
create categorical variables.
Here is a list of examples: if the feature is 1, the class is a and if the feature is 3.2,
the class is b. In
this first example, the class pie is used to classify and output a function and
select a method.  And you can use this classification function to better predict a new example class.
If the feature is 1.5 then the class will be a and
if it is 3.5 then the class will be b.
This is a simple example of a project.  This function is
very similar to Living Phi, but instead of predicting living, it
predicts real numbers. For example, you can use this predicting function for the new 0.
This is a slightly more interesting example.
Here is the Titanic passenger.  Load a machine-learned example of data
about each passenger predicts whether or not the passengers were able to survive as a function of the
passenger characteristics, that is, the throwing
age and gender of the embarkation point, as you
can see in the data.  There are some things that are missing, but in the case of living defeats and
projects  You can handle
data. Apply + file to this data.
I chose the method here, but you don't have
to choose the method. Actually, the best method is chosen by not choosing the method.
But I want to use it.  You can also use it if you have a method
categorized and output a
function It is very likely that this person died when using this function on a 28 year old man who was on board on a new day
You
can also ask for
a probability. According to the model of the data, you can see that the probability of this passenger disappearing is 93%
.The important thing is that all classification functions can be used to ask for a probability.
Very useful if you want to combine models or make some decisions about them.
This is a
plot of survival probability as a function of age for different gender and boarding throw combinations. Take
another example image.
This is an example of a handwritten number image
You can enter this data if you have a class
Here we will incorporate 10,000 Suzutake due to time constraints
and use training speed for performance goals
Is one of the performance goal values that specifies what kind of classification you want to use. You
c
n specify it in the performance goal, such as whether you want to use a fast training classification or want to reduce memory usage
Here's a categorized function
that loads the test data that isn't included in the training data to test this. Here are
10 random samples of the test example.
Let's use this as an example, for example.  If
you put in 6, will it be recognized as 6?
It was recognized properly.
To do this more scientifically, use the function of Living Fire Measures.
Enter the classification and test data here.
It outputs a living fire measure face object.
You can query various properties for this object.
For example, if you want to know the living fire angle to a dataset, you will find that this is a 93%
angle.
You can also plot the Kondo
matrix from this matrix, for example, in the test set 821, although the following examples are correctly classified.
You can see that it
was incorrectly classified as 6 and you can also see an example that was actually misclassified as 6
Here is an example of a simple text
that is a real-life example.  The text is not about cats or
about dogs. This is
another example using an image, but it's an example of a project. I
have a gauge image that contains a value. I
'll try to predict the value as a function of the image.
And this predictive function can be used in the image to predict the value of this gauge
given quite close given that
you can also ask for the grammar
classifications establish  I was able to find it, but here I can find a continuous distribution. The distribution that
can be
predicted from this image and stopped even if a function is used
is a normal distribution centered around 0.75 with such a standard deviation.
It's a tool for predicting and checking the target.
There is also a tool for identifying the topic of the post on
facebook. Please also see the other examples posted here. I
have shown some examples above.  For more information on machine learning, see the
Class Fight Project documentation
. There is also a guide page for machine learning.
There is also a new feature page for version stores with various examples.
Which team will win the World Cup?
There is also a blog written before the World Cup that predicted that
this example is an example where you can see a complete machine learning word processor with Matty or through real problems
.
Thank you for your attention.